There's chaos in you. The fun of moon knight is
getting introduced to a new superhero in a new
world it's a real legitimate character study i
can't tell the difference between my waking lives
and dreams moon knight is a spectacular
character's got an incredibly unique visual look
our job was to kind of put a lens on
the things that had the most uh dramatic
juice and ultimately take the mental
health aspect incredibly seriously i am
stephen the way we're tackling the story we
learn about steven and then learn about marc
what's wrong with you marc why did you
call me marc and they're the same person
the tone is like fight club meets indiana jones
it's a bit dark at times to tie it into something
so vast and supernatural it's amazing thank you
every aspect of this show has a duality and we've
shifted the paradigm for me what's really
exciting is that it's totally unpredictable
Welcome back everyone this is my new marvel moon
knight trailer video they released a whole bunch
of new footage so we'll break it all down there's
a bunch of easter eggs here and we're going to be
getting episodes in a couple weeks so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get them all i will be doing videos for all the
episodes like i do for all the other marvel disney
plus series we'll do a giveaway for disney plus
memberships all you have to do to enter is just be
a subscriber and leave your favorite moment from
the trailer on the video this trailer gives us a
lot more footage of his different transformations
between different personalities and different
versions of moon knight at the beginning of this
you see him transform to the regular version of
marc spector moon knight i think the idea is that
when he's in regular moon knight form like this
version of the costume he is his regular original
marc spector personality they said they're kind
of starting the series rashaman style where you
actually start a little bit later in the story
after he's become moon knight or after he's
developed the different personalities so when
we start he thinks he's stephen grant and then he
starts hearing all these things about marc spector
like he gets the phone call why did you call me
marc then it sounds like we flash back to the
origin story and they show us how he became moon
knight how he ran into khanshu got his powers and
developed the different personalities marc spector
is former regular military who became a mercenary
wound up working for this warlord trying to pilfer
this egyptian dig site we see some footage that
looks kind of like that in the trailer like
you see ethan hawk's arthur harrow character
seems like he's using the special scarab artifact
to find some special archaeology dig site in the
comics he wound up getting into a fight with that
warlord is left for dead then basically crawls his
way to the statue of khanshu at the nearby dig
site we see a version of that in the trailer
like you're getting bits of what looks like his
origin story throughout this trailer because
kanchi was trapped in this other dimension with
his pantheon of gods he can't physically enter
the main mcu universe but he can work through
avatars he sees an opportunity in marc spector
he tells him i'll save your life if you become
my avatar on earth and you execute my will the
problem is is that konshu is this very capricious
god like you see all this footage where he's
trying to run from him but i think this is when
he thinks that he's still stephen grant not marc
spector there's different footage of him inside
this special temple where you see all these other
egyptian gods in the background at least that's
what it looks like like he's in this place with
these other egyptian gods and in the background
you actually see stephen grant just walking by
like he's marc spector looking at stephen grant
in the background they could play this as if
he's been transported to this other dimension by
konshu to speak to him there and the other gods
or they could be playing this as if concho is
just speaking to him in his mind and his physical
body has not left the main mcu dimension then we
see him in the streets of egypt being an actual
mercenary like he's chasing someone down this is
when he's still marc spector you can kind of tell
just based on the costumes that they're wearing
which personality he's in i love the way they pull
this scene off too like he falls out the window as
either steven grant or marc spector and lands as
the mr knight persona now in the comics mr knight
is the one who wears this white looking suit it's
just another version of his moon knight costume
on the series they might just be playing it as if
this is another version of the marc spector moon
knight persona like i don't know how many of the
personalities we're gonna see on the actual tv
show in the more recent comics it gets up to four
different personalities but like they might not
be doing the jake lockley cab driver persona they
might just be doing steven grant and marc spector
the mr knight persona with the white suit and the
tie is a little bit more recent in the comics and
to make a batman reference that's sort of like
the world's greatest detective version of moon
knight he uses the mr knight persona to actually
liaise with the police on detective cases we get a
little more footage of ethan hawk's arthur harrow
character and it seems like he's after the same
type of god tier power that moon knight gains as
a result of his connection with konchu only some
of the artifacts that arthur harrow has seem like
they're connected to the egyptian god sobek the
alligator god like he has an alligator on his
little cane there he has an alligator tattoo a
lot of you also asking me if i think that he's
gonna become a version of shadow knight from
the comics if you don't know who shadow knight
is that's sort of like an evil darker version of
moon knight like moon knight is already meant to
be kind of a dark character but in the comics
marc spector had a brother really early in his
run that he wound up fighting kind of turned evil
that marc spector wound up having to take down
later we find out that his brother was actually
part of the cult of conscie and for a brief period
got the same powers as moon knight from konchu
but they called him shadow knight so it was like
a more evil version of moon knight that might be
what's happening with the arthur hero character
like it seems like he's trying to hijack some of
this god tier power that must be very difficult
embrace the chaos in the comics arthur harrow was
this former nazi scientist whose field was the
study of pain and within the context of the series
it looks like they're carrying over his disability
he suffered from a condition which left him
paralyzed on his left side in the state of
constant pain so he studies pain as a way to
try and fix that but it seems like ethan hawk
is playing a combination of a couple different
characters in the mcu and that just informs
his indiana jones nazi-like search for these
special god tier artifacts they did make a lot
of indiana jones references when they talked about
creating the series like the special treasure hunt
aspect of the series where they're searching for
artifacts to give them power of the gods and it
also takes place in egypt but when you see arthur
harrow he's inside this same temple place where
you see it seems like the gods standing behind him
here where we saw them sitting down earlier with
marc spector so somehow he's gained access to the
same special place this plane of existence with
this other dimension where the gods are the brand
new female character that we see in all these
scenes is also the woman whose voice we heard on
the phone call calling him marc spector like wait
a minute why are you calling me marc she sounds
like she knew him before he became moon knight and
developed the split personalities her character's
name is layla inside the mcu but she might be a
combination of a couple different characters
including his love interest marlene from the
comics we also get a much better look at kanchu
himself this is what his head basically looks like
if he didn't realize because we haven't heard
him actually speak during any of these trailers
he's being voiced by f murray abraham
which i think is going to be amazing
cw i need you to draft an apology immediately
of course now are we apologizing to the nazis or
on their behalf you all probably remember him from
somewhere just because he's done so many amazing
movies and tv shows more recently he's actually
been doing that mythic quest comedic series
the whole idea with the power that kanchu grants
moon knight is that because kanchu is pretending
to be the egyptian god of the moon moon knight's
powers are tied to the phases of the moon the
more full the moon is the more powerful he becomes
like he's at his most powerful during a full moon
but khanshu is actually lying about being the
egyptian moon god he's actually much older than
that the pantheon that he comes from is actually
part of the elder gods that were around millions
of years ago inside the main mcu dimension but
were eventually banished i know there are lots
of theories about what's going on with scarlet
witch during doctor strange 2 because of the dark
hold where chaos magic comes from in the mcu if
they're going to be including any catholic easter
eggs but the cool connection to the darkhold is
that cathone is also part of that same pantheon of
elder gods that konchu came from they're changing
some stuff inside the mcu so it won't be exactly
like it is in the comics though this scene of
konchu talking to marc spector where it seems like
reality is spinning around them in the background
seems like he's just explaining the gods in all of
existence to him like just revealing the truth
of all existence it's sort of like him getting
a version of that doctor strange magical tour of
the multiverse in the first doctor strange movie
where the ancient one just sensing through all
these different dimensions like open your mind
reality is much crazier than you thought it
was it'll get a little bit crazier during
doctor strange too thanks to the addition of all
those x-men crossover characters in the fantastic
four showing up because the moonite episodes will
overlap with doctor strange multiverse of madness
i'm also wondering if they're going to reference
the other dimensions where these gods live
during doctor strange we're also getting thor
love and thunder later this summer where gore
the godbutcher christian bale's character is going
to be going around killing all the gods of the mcu
konchu being another god would be on his hit
list so maybe kanchu and his pantheon will also
be referenced during thor love and thunder he is
going to cross over with other big marvel phase 4
movies and he will eventually cross over into
avengers 5 with the other avengers characters
i believe there's supposed to be a special
avengers cameo scene either towards the end
of the series or some point during the series
involving either mark ruffalo's hook character
or it could be someone else i think they're
going to have something similar to the shengxi
post credit scene where you have the hulk and a
couple other characters there just referencing a
lot of avengers stuff and those have their own
version of that during the moon knight series
i believe the rumor right now is that it's going
to be mark ruffalo and he'll be showing up in some
capacity as a version of bruce banner but not the
hulk which is why i made the shangshi reference
because during that scene he was just in banner
form like he wasn't hulked out there's actually
a really cool connection between the whole
character and moon knight in the comics that goes
way back to his origin story in the comics moonite
actually debuted as a villain in the werewolf by
night comic book that's why werewolf by night is
supposed to show up during the moon knight series
but he wasn't meant to be a recurring character
he was just like a one-off villain that showed
up and tried to take down werewolf by night but
then wound up helping him out he was so popular
that marvel editorial told them to bring the
character back so marvel brought him back in
the backup stories for the hook magazine that
was running at the time it's not the same thing
as the hulk comic books the hulk magazine was
intended for more adult readers darker stories
so the hulk and moon knight go way way back but
it is going to be totally crazy episodes are going
to be starting at the end of the month of course
i'll be doing videos for all of them so make sure
you have alerts enabled for my channel so you
don't miss anything i'll name a giveaway winner
in my next big marvel video i have another big
star wars obi-wan kenobi trailer video that i'm
working on i'll talk a little bit about darth
vader and what's going on with grogu in ahsoka
during the events of that series wait wait for
everything click here for that brand new obi-wan
kenobi trailer video in easter eggs and click here
for my brand new doctor strange 2 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!